voici un autre exemple de la difficulté
de vivre sans électricité nous allons à
présent dans le secteur de Marvejol en
loszer où les habitants comme les
touristes sont logés à la même enseigne
ils attendent le retour du courant dans
le froid correspondance Karine comadzi
et Cyril Paquier comme 6000 autres
foyers dans le nord de la Lozère cette
maison est plongée dans l'obscurité
depuis plus de 24 Hees les premiers
voisins sont loin et EDF les
bienvenu la lumière demain dans la
journée cette famille de Parisiens avait
loué le git pour la semaine de Noël
on se
retrouve dans des conditions de vie
qu'on n' pas l'habitude he étant donné
qu'on a tout le temps de l'eau chaud de
chauffage c'est pas désagréable mais on
se dit qu' on sait pas si on est capable
de le supporter très
long du coup l'immanche Baptiste s'est
réduite à une pièces de vie près de la
cheminée les bougies du réveillon jouent
les prolongations et les activités sont
plutôt
réduites on a pris les piles de la lande
de poche pour faire marcher la radio
c'est comme ça qu'on a su qu'on était
pas les seuls en France à avoir ce genre
de problème on n pas pris de douche du
tout aujourd'hui hein donc parce qu'on
avait pas pas d'eau chaude pas assez
d'eau chaude donc et ben on s'est pas
laver mais on se dit que grâce à EDF on
se lavera
bientôt queedf répare il vaut mieux que
répar - 5 degr est l'obscurité totale
dans les étables de ces agriculteurs
laériens autre fois aussi quand on
allait au bêes on avait les lanternes
vous savez à pétrole ou et et ça aussi
bon on a bien cherché toutes les lampes
mais elles n'ont pas marché depuis si
longtemps qu'elles ont pas voulu la vie
à la campagne c'est heureusement les
réserves mais problème le meilleur est
dans le congélateur si on les ouvre les
congélateurs après bon il y a il y a pas
mal de viande d'abîmé ou tout ça 22h la
lumière vient sauver le congélateur et
60 familles du secteur pour plus de 7000
autres il faudra encore se contenter du
soleil